foreign
ER is with us in uh Atlanta Georgia hey
Connor welcome to the Ramsey Show
good afternoon Dave and George how are
y'all better than we deserve man what's
up
I have been living on rice and beans for
years and I am scared to live a little
how many years oh about six
um currently 22.
um I've I've been in yeah I took your
class in high school my parents taught
me to leave the Ramsay way uh tripped
and fell a couple times but uh I didn't
go to college and just instantly started
saving every penny I made you know
didn't live off time just save save save
how much money do you have now
I'm currently about 200 000. good for
you how old are you 22. 22.
you're an old man
and um and what what's your household
income sir
uh about 160 000 a year what do you do
for a living
I am a call truck driver wow you're
killing it okay
um okay let's clarify a couple things
the Ramsay way is live like no one else
so that later
you can live
and give like no one else that's the
Ramsay way not living in a cave and
collecting lint and only coming out on
Triple Coop on Thursday the rest of your
life
that's not the Ramsay way okay so
generosity and enjoyment
should increase as wealth increases
okay and I think you're just stuck on
the saving part of the button aren't you
yeah I'm you know I'm I'm scared to
really touch any of it um yeah we've got
a flat tire so we've got give save spend
that's the only three things you can do
with money and you're great at the
savings part and so what I would do if
I'm in your shoes is I would force
myself to have some goals in the giving
Arena and the spending Arena that
frivolous that feel crazy for Conor at
20. oh my gosh I can't believe I'm
spending this much on a vacation I can't
believe I'm gonna tip that waitress a
thousand dollars but man when you do it
it is going to be so freeing Conor uh if
I were to step back if if you were to
step outside of your body for a minute
and just look at your life from a
distance and you were looking at your
whole situation what's something Conor
should be spending money on that he's
not
oh man I mean
I'm not sure just give me two things
there's two things you are sure you know
exactly what I meant
I mean I'd eventually like a vacation a
vacation what would be an outrageous
vacation for you in your mind
Australia okay and what would you spend
on this outrageous vacation
oh I don't know maybe ten thousand
dollars okay and you have two hundred
thousand right
yeah most of it's tied up though what's
it tied up in
the stock market
in mutual funds or stocks or
uh mainly stocks retirement account
I have 401k about 60 000 that's in 401.
it's not tied up if it's in a stock
honey you put in a sell order and you
have the money by tomorrow
it's not tied up at all there's no rope
involved in the stock market they don't
use rope there
okay
okay it's it you're thinking of it
properly as a long-term investment not
something to jump in and out of but
let's pretend that tomorrow you had one
hundred and ninety thousand instead of
200.
would you still be okay
oh yeah okay
so I think George is right maybe even we
baby steps maybe we don't spend ten
thousand maybe we spend five thousand
and we go somewhere other than Australia
because you do need to spend 10 if
you're going to go there but the um but
but you know let's baby step it and say
I'm gonna because what's happening is
Georgia's exactly right the tire's flat
and those muscles haven't been worked
and we need to work a giving muscle
and we need to work a spending muscle so
pick out a number that you're going to
splurge on giving
and find something that makes you cry
hungry children
in the burn Ward or the Cancer Ward I
don't know what is it that makes you cry
and give them some money
and find something for you and take that
same exact amount of money and go do a
trip
and start to build this muscle maybe
find a hobby
Dave picked up golfing no no don't do
that
don't do that that'll it causes all
kinds of too much stress there's too
much mental illness associated with that
no but yeah find something that's fun
yeah don't do that